why don't you talk about what the super
force is and how you believe that solves
some of the problems in quantum gravity
okay
it's interesting because you can say
this would go back to sir isaac newton
uh
i think it was 1693
i could be possibly wrong with you he
writes a letter to his friend in which
he says what if
what if gravity is caused by an agent
capital a
that acts
constantly in accordance with given laws
of nature
why
what if this agent capital a
is the super force and what i mean by
the super force would be like the force
of unification the force would that
would rule over the other forces
and
equalize
all forces
i believe it does exist
at the plank scale
now why at the planck scale
look carefully at the structure of
general relativity formalism that's used
by einstein and i shall not use richie
or
reminding curvature formalism i'll use
einstein tensor so g sub mu nu
equals what a eight
pi
big g divided by c to the fourth the
whole thing times t sub mu nu that t sum
you knew again representative energy
density
but look carefully at that scalar
constant
it has a term in it c to the fourth
divided by big g
well if you
do the math
that term comes from a in blank energy
divided
by planck length
so
your blank mass times c square the whole
thing divided by g h bar divided by c
cube the whole thing one half
the thing comes up with c to the fourth
divided by g
how can you get a planck force
featuring within
general relativity and it goes further
you can find the c to the fourth
divided by big g
what's
i term the super force
this force of unification in the dirac
equation which is the relativistic form
of schrodinger equation the foundational
form formalism of quantum mechanics
which is absolutely remarkable that the
c to the fourth divided by g should
figure not only that but the super force
equals the planck force
and the blank force does not have h bar
in it so it's nonplanking in nature it's
classical which means the super force
which equals the planned force at the
blank scale
is the bridge
between the world of the very large
namely general relativity
and the world of the very small
represented by quantum field theory and
according to
professor j armas this is what's needed
a force of unification a bridge
that would unify all four known forces
in this case including gravity even
though some people think of it as
non-force they think of it as a
space-time geometric curvature
but if you look carefully okay and now
that i've said what i've said with the
c4
c to the fourth divided by big g
look carefully at einstein equation it
can be reformulated it actually saying
that the super force
acting on the space-time geometric
structure
gives rise to energy density hence
matter
and you can just see by rearranging the
terms of the equation that that's
exactly what's saying not only that if
you look carefully at the bekenstein
hawking formulation for entropy of a
black hole
c to the fourth divided by big g also
features in that because your entropy of
a black hole would be given as h bar
divide actually
k sub b which is the boltzmann constant
divided by h bar c
that term times c to the fourth divided
by g
times your area of the black hole
that would be your entropy
and you can actually see that i'm
correct the actual and the significant
again is that it is the super force
acting on the area of the black hole
that generates this black hole entropy
hence i believe it's the super force
that's the bridge the c to the fourth
divided by big g
which is non-plank in nature acts as the
bridge between the world of the very
large and the world of the very small
and it is it exists at the plank scale
at every point in space and time
okay so help me understand what does it
mean when you say that it acts on it so
firstly let me make this clear when you
say super force you're referring to the
planck force
and people can look at what the flank
force is yes okay yes and then secondly
when you say it acts on it so let's
imagine we have
g
equals k times t
and forget about g is
einstein forget i'm just making up some
variables actually i could have said x
equals k times y
i wouldn't say
k is acting on y
but you're saying k is acting on y in
that case so what does that mean to me i
see that as a proportionality constant
so that's like a conversion factor
okay so think of the analogy between the
main formula of general relativity g sub
mu nu equal that scalar constant times d
sub mu nu now
transform it into
dimensional
character just think of it
would be one divided by l square where
your l would be some characteristic
length could be the planck length equal
um
l divided by e
times e divided by l cubed what's the u
energy okay right
right e the by by l cube that's your
energy density term well
what is a force it's a it's really the
gradient of an inert of an energy that's
why that e divided by l is really your
super force and if you
just
put that term on the other side it's
actually saying it's the super force
acting on your
space-time geometric curvature that
yields your energy density hence matter
so i believe it is the super force that
generates matter
based on whatever that space-time
geometric curvature local
in that particular domain is
so you could actually have a different
idea of what
it's just remarkable what einstein has
come up with it's it's
if you just restructure it you see a
whole different meaning of his formula
but still and it says it is the super
force
acting on the space-time geometric
structure
that gives rise to energy density hence
matter
that is interesting i think
it's new anyway
it's just a new way of looking it's just
a new
perspective on old physics
okay so let me state it in my words and
see if this aligns with what you're
saying yes sir okay so traditionally in
einstein's equations you have g which
which colloquially is space time and so
geometry and then on the right side
there's t which is the stress energy
tensor which is thought of as the matter
now these are coupled but you can think
of it as
geometry and then there's some
proportionality constant in the matter
now you're saying that it's eight pi
divided by the planck force so let's
just move the plank force to this side
so planck force times the geometry
equals eight pi times the
matter distribution you can think of the
super force or the planck force in this
case
what is the super force it is the planck
force because it acts at the planck
scale so therefore the super force
equals the blank force so
what that equation now says it's the
super force that's acting on the space
time geometric structure that yields
your t sum your nu your energy density
which represents matter
okay i'm going to need to think about
that some more because i still don't see
so the way that i see it is that okay
cool these numbers come up in a couple
different places it comes up in
quantum mechanics and it comes up in
relativity and these are what we're
trying to merge keep in mind c to the
fourth divided by big g why should it
come up in the dirac equation by a
manipulation of the terms
in the dirac equation or the schrodinger
equation and also in general relativity
and just think of it actually even
easier than that
if
this force c to the fourth divided by
big g
why should it be nonplanking in a
classical realm
because it is planck energy divided by
uh planck length that all of a sudden
loses its hbar term so it becomes
classical why
because the super force must exist and
it's 10 to the 44th newtons
i believe it actually ah it acts at what
um
eventually we're going to talk about the
ashtakar bounce point
and you can give more in your podcast
you understand this because you read the
right yeah so astrocarb's bounce what
what sal is referring to is this paper
called the robustness of key features of
quantum of loop quantum cosmology so
people can look that up that will be in
the description
okay now you're saying this bounce is
relevant to your work because
because i'm saying it's the super force
that acts at the planck scales that's at
this bounce point this ashtakar bounce
point
that actually
you can think of it as saying thus far
and no further by actually saying there
are no space-time singularities
it doesn't go to zero
it goes to the splanc scale
it's exactly what professor ashtakar
talks about when he talks about his
bounds
i believe it is the super force that
acts at this bounce that prevents
any so-called space-time singularities
from forming